Catherine Newton um really quickly told
me that you were so great to her such a
mother figure to her but she said that
on the flip side you would always ask
her advice about you know your daughter
and things like that and how did you
know is it okay for her to go to India
and go to yeah go to Coachella yes my a
teenage consultant parenting and also
I'm like what is the thing on Instagram
and what does it mean with this hashtag
and she's like oh that's not that
Katherine's awesome you ever have to sit
and look at your daughter Ava and say is
that really me I was looking at a
picture of you guys not too long ago and
I was just back and forth like I can't
really tell the difference between
spending re an hour premiere for that
movie staying at over Christmas and the
head of the studio went up to Ava and
congratulated her on the baby right no I
I just love her I'm so lucky to be your
mom and I just love having her in my
life and getting to go everywhere it's
so great honor
[Music]
Oh